the Joe Rogan experience I don't I've
been not getting news like I just came
through things these days it's so
frustrating there's first of all there's
too many series to follow
there's the Obama Gate series gotta
follow that case nut case nut case the
the the CD sitting president exiting
president literally hires or gets the
FBI to investigate Trump I don't know
anything about Obama gate but I did see
a takedown of Obama gate that was pretty
harsh where the guy was like it's
basically relies on you having to
believe a series of conspiracy theories
in order for it to even hold up and I am
just gonna sit here right now before
everyone's all like I know nothing about
Obama gate and I actually don't give a
[ __ ] I might fit an older video that
might have been an old oh it's from last
night mmm listen to Jimmy doors video on
it Jimmy doors video is excellent and
yeah he breaks down exactly what the
administration did yeah and that it's
illegal and that you're you're you're
essentially using the FBI to spy on
Trump and then when it turned out that
all that Russia stuff that they were
claiming was going to happen didn't take
place and that they knew it wasn't
really happening to begin with that what
what they were saying was all
exaggerating and hyperbole and they were
trying to turn it into something that it
wasn't good it's not good because what's
the other story that we need to follow
there's so many series there's so many
going on right now right this is Joe
Biden losing his [ __ ] mind
oh like do they have him locked in a
basement somewhere and they're pumping
out with steroids and coke right before
he does right they do like a whole
fortnight thing where he was gonna be a
you know what are they called a hologram
and fortnight or something and I'm like
this is gonna be our first hologram
hologram debate do you put anything
beyond the realm of possibility at the
point that we're at though in in the
world doesn't feel like we live in a
[ __ ] simulation it does Kevin Rose you
know Kevin rose from dig he put
something up on his page a couple of
days ago i retweeted it it's the new
unreal
engin unreal five oh I saw that he's
[ __ ] insane it's [ __ ] insane
it's like movie stuff and it's in-game
action so yeah in-game action now
there's there's a scene where the the
character that you're playing it's a
third-person game and you're moving this
girl around and she runs up this hill
and as she runs up the hill you see like
rocks falling and you see the shadows
it's spectacular and Kevin said you know
he tweeted it to me and he said look at
this and imagine I believe he said 25 50
100 years from now of course we're in a
simulation because this is this is going
to be just as realistic and 25 50 100
years from now as the world that you're
experiencing right now but isn't there
the question that we don't know that
this isn't is the question I mean Nick
Bostrom explained it to me that I was my
feeble brain was having a hard time
calculating but he's basically saying
that according to probability theory we
are in a simulation it's more probable
that we are then that we're not my
friend was saying that they would start
doing things like this leading you to
believe you're in a simulation of people
in the simulation started becoming
self-aware they'd start making you think
you're in a simulation so that you could
doubt it of course little built-in
failsafe yeah of course but that makes
sense right so I'm gonna ask you Jimmy
door you get news from him I do
news from Kyle kolinsky Jimmy door my
political news is all from the hill
Jimmy door and Kyle kolinsky the hill is
crystal and Sandra always say his name
room that they have a really good
political show okay Kyle kolinsky is
very well versed in exactly what's going
on and he's critical both sides as his
Jimmy Dore like Jimmy do neither one of
those is partisan both those guys even
though they're left both progressive
guys they're very open minded right and
they're very honest about what's what's
going wrong and what's wrong about it
Jimmy Dore especially he has some
[ __ ] epic rants an epigram nationally
about when people tried to whitewash the
the negative things that happened during
the
Obama administration he's like you guys
are gas lighting people look this is
what happens when you have your standard
you know this is this is the
relationship right a guy goes into
office he promises a bunch of stuff
can't really do them but people like the
way he talks does some things that maybe
aren't so good you find out later and
then he gets out he makes [ __ ] loads of
money doing speeches and jimmy dore
highlights that that he's making easy
even openly talking about that press
Correspondents Dinner you know that joke
yeah yeah he talked about I was gonna
try those lines out at Goldman Sachs
yeah yeah and he said he was gonna make
him some serious tougher taking over all
the streaming I saw a whole thing about
how the Obamas I think are they're
getting into the streaming game and I
read somewhere that the Clintons are
that could be wrong well the Obamas
apparently have some sort of a deal with
Netflix to produce shows documentaries
and then they have a deal where they do
in podcast did you like Obama rate I'd
like him as a spokesperson like as a
figurehead of who the president is I
mean he's a handsome guy he's incredibly
articulate really well-spoken the way
speaks is like a statesman you know I
mean he's always calm and collected
there's a lot about him I really like
there's a lot about him but politics is
a crazy messy impossible to do right
business then no one is nailed
especially at the highest levels no
one's nailed it I don't know why he
didn't do what he said he was gonna do
before he got into office I don't know
what they revealed to him I don't know
but when you listen if someone does an
accurate job of breaking down what went
wrong particularly what's going on with
this Flynn case yeah they're trying to
drop all the charges and then some new
judges coming in say no we're not
dropping [ __ ] I just feel so
ill-equipped to process this stuff yeah
because I'm not a lawyer I'm not a
politician I'm an idiot on YouTube thank
you right here and I don't know anything
and and I often hear even in my comments
on the dumpster fire they're like oh I
get all my news from you and Joe
now don't you don't do that don't do
that bad no don't get from me are you no
no I have not a trusted news source but
that I'm like but I don't know who is
yeah I don't know who is either I'm here
to talk [ __ ] okay and if I'm wrong which
is often I will let you know I'm not
here to lie but I'm here to talk [ __ ] to
do yeah I mean I I don't the the show we
just basically make fun of how bonkers
everything is and I but I don't have any
answers I don't know with a freaking
pathway forward out of this ship show is
and seems like it's going to get worse
before it gets better which is my fear
[Applause]